[Music]
Jeff Snyder here at the Kia Telluride
supper Suite in Park City and I'm
sitting down with the team behind black
bear we've got the three stars of the
film Aubry Plaza Sarah Gaden and
Christopher Abbott guys thanks for
joining us thanks for having us
Aubrey I'm gonna put you on the spot
first you got to tell the folks at home
what is this movie about describe it a
little well it's kind of one of those
movies that you're that you really
shouldn't know too much about before you
see it
um but I would describe it as an
escalation of
um a nightmarish
um unconscious you're unconscious mind
trying to come through in the most
nightmarish way possible I actually I
don't know what I'm talking about well
do you play like a filmmaker who goes
like yeah sorry sorry sorry sorry it's
too early okay the plot of the film
right I play a filmmaker and I go to a
lake house property that is owned by
um Sarah gadden and Christopher Abbott's
characters who are married in the first
half
how am I doing so far
okay okay things get crazy but you can't
wait to see it now all right well the
the description says that your character
is struggling with some inner demons I
was curious that's what I was trying to
say about the unconscious mind it's
there's it's a jungian kind of exercise
on you know
I don't know
all the collider viewers know uh what
jungian means okay
um doing great Sarah and Chris um what
What attracted you to this project made
you want to sign on
really needed the money at the time and
um
no the writing is really good
um it felt like it was not gonna it kind
of almost felt like working on a play
um it's pretty verbose and so I was kind
of excited about the challenge of that
um and then I was kind of just genuinely
excited to work with Larry and these
guys
um I think because I came out a little
bit later so I uh it was the crew it was
the group mostly
yeah I think it was the writing and um
and everybody involved
Aubry
um yeah feel the same way about you yeah
well let me ask you guys
um did it help being directed by a
fellow actor in Lawrence Michael Levine
someone who sort of understands the
perspective that you guys are coming at
the material from no definitely not
sometimes that can make things more
tricky
um
yes it was helpful Larry is Larry one
thing I love about Larry is that he
really cares about the acting process
and he thinks about performance and he
he thinks about things that some
directors wouldn't think about because
he he knows that process well so it is
nice to be directed by someone that kind
of thinks that way he did this really
weird thing where he was like I don't
want you guys to talk about the film
with each other unless I'm I'm present
okay there's like a lot of that [ __ ]
going on
he's not here so we can say whatever we
want yeah absolutely and he's never
gonna watch this as soon as you lose
Larry except he probably will and and
where did you guys shoot where was this
uh remote uh location that you guys went
off to up in the Adirondacks and town
called in Long Lake right New York yeah
small town up in the not around
internet yeah
yeah Saranac Lake
um and you guys are all uh Sundance
Veterans of the festival what does this
Festival mean to you guys and and you
know how special it is to come back to
it
trouble breathing
um
bloody noses
uh heightened emotions High emotions
stress yeah no it's great I mean it's
like it's uh
I don't know it's it's it's it's it's
nice to I I equate going to like a film
festival like if I was like a musician
and going to like
a music festival and I could I you you
play your show and you get to see like
your friends play their show and I enjoy
it for that reason
um it makes it feel like a community and
I like the sense of community it is
still filmed like black bear here which
is a wonderful weird bizarre intelligent
film
has such a warm reception at a place
because this is where movies like that
can have a life so it's great in that
regard too yes I would add on to that
and say it's a great it's just a great
um collection of people that are all
here because they love movies so it's
it's just nice to be you know in that
community and support you know everyone
else's films and it's just a nice time
it's like we're all here for the right
reasons and it's fun and
um there's an element of danger you know
with nature mother nature
um you never know what what could happen
snow rain
got to be prepared that's right
um I'm seeing a lot of prominent actors
and actresses step behind the camera
these days so I'm curious if if you guys
have any plans to direct yourself
anytime soon I do yeah yeah absolutely
you working on anything fellow NYU I
know right no nothing I can talk about
but no I want to
yeah okay I'll hit up your MGMT folks
okay
uh either you guys I think a long time I
used to say no like I wouldn't I was
very kind of would have like a Japanese
mentality of like you know sticking to
one trade and then trying to be really
good at that and then actually I think I
started to change my tune a little bit
lately because
um the more I work on movies the more I
feel like I can do it better
you can
I'm just kidding but yeah I still know
nothing of it not officially but I think
I'm opening my mind a little bit more
all right yeah yeah Sarah any any uh
aspirations to do anything like that
yeah just optioned a novel oh adapt yeah
can you say what novel it is uh yeah
it's called lullabies for little
criminals by Heather O'Neill sounds good
I like that title let's hope so good
luck with the adaptation Chris you just
wrapped a directorial debut uh drug
Carmichael's on the count of three what
can you tell us about that one it sounds
a little wild
um yeah I'm very excited about that one
um
it's uh draw directed it but he's in it
also with me and we're um two friends
that um
uh wanna want to kill ourselves
and so it might do it for each other or
might not all right that's about that's
pretty much but it's it's it's slightly
comedic in town and dramatic it's
there's a lot to it any idea when we'll
see that will that be out before I have
no idea he's editing now so
um yeah I have no idea and speaking of
wild movies I'm looking forward to Sarah
I understand you're in Vampires versus
the Bronx
yeah from the SNL director right Oz
Rodriguez yeah like what's your role in
that
um I don't wanna I I don't want to give
it away
um because she has a bit of a turn but I
had so much fun making that movie with
Oz he's so great and Chris red is also
so funny and wonderful so that was a lot
of fun well I'm looking forward to that
when I got like an attack the black Vibe
yeah
um is there anything you guys are
looking forward to uh seeing here at the
festival while you're here I know Chris
has another movie possessor I know
possessor are you guys excited about
that yeah yeah good I just love the
title possessor yeah so intriguing
anything else on the lineup while you're
in town here the nest I want to say
tomorrow yeah is there a movie called
boys state yes I want to see that I've
heard good things yeah
okay not gonna get to if you're here in
Park City make sure to check out black
bear guys thanks for joining us thank
you to the Kia Telluride supper Suite uh
the team from black bear thank you